Meaningful use is a complex program in
three stages that coordinates with the approach to provider reimbursement for Medicare.
We can only cover the main points here.
The central goals of Meaningful Use are the use of
certified EHR technology in a clinically meaningful manner,
such as e-prescribing, for electronic exchange of health information to improve
quality of health care and to submit clinical quality and other measures.
The sub-goals for clinical care include: improving care coordination,
reducing health care disparities,
engaging patients and their families,
improving population and public health,
and ensuring adequate privacy and security.
Note that these goals align well with what experts
believe is needed to improve the management of chronic disease.
The developers of Meaningful Use were well aware of the mismatch we discussed in lesson
one between the focus of our healthcare system and the diseases that drive most costs.
This Meaningful Use timeline from the CDC shows that the program began in 2010,
and starting in 2015,
there were reductions in Medicare payments to
hospitals and providers that were not Meaningful Users.
The timeline in stage 3,
in particular, is highly political.
Many argue that the pace of the program is too rapid given
the complexity of implementing and properly
integrating these systems into a health care organization.
The CDC generally does a good job of clearly explaining the program,
so I would recommend their site for updates.
Next, we'll turn to some of the challenges of EHRs and their adoption.